[Music]
certifications have served as a stepping
stone for anybody seeking to advance in
their careers whether they are beginners
or seasoned professionals according to
robert half's 2021 it salary report it
professionals with certifications earn 5
to 10 percent more than their peers
so in this video we'll go over the
finest certifications that can help you
attain a good compensation package
at number 10 we have web development
web development has been around for a
long time since every company needs a
website to advertise or sell their
products
this domain typically comprises three
categories front-end development
back-end development and full stack
development a certification in any
programming language such as python
nodejs html css javascript or angular
might improve your chances of snagging a
lucrative job offer
however if you are more inclined towards
full stack development than simply
learns postgraduate program in full
stack web development in collaboration
with caltech might prove to be an
amazing option for you
this extensive course covers 13
different web development tools enabling
you to master front end and back end
development along with devops lifecycle
the average salary for this domain
ranges from 62 000 to 158 000 in the us
and 13.7 lakh to 30 lakh rupees in india
next up we have number nine cyber
security
working remotely has become the new norm
since the covid epidemic but this has
brought a lot of cyber threats with it
due to remote access to it
infrastructure and the use of
collaboration tools on endpoint devices
to prevent cyber attacks companies need
certified cyber security and networking
professionals some of the popular
networking certifications you can pick
up our comp tia network plus
certification will provide you with
fundamental knowledge of networking
concepts network security network
operations and troubleshooting you can
also take up the cissp
cisco ccna and ccnp certifications these
certifications are considered
professional level certifications they
can show off your ability to work with
cisco networking solutions
a network engineer or cyber security
expert earns approximately eighty four
thousand to a hundred and sixty four
thousand per annum in the united states
and five lakh to 40 lakh rupees in india
at number eight we have agile scrum
scrum is a common framework for
collaborating with teams scrum
procedures enable businesses to
efficiently adjust with rapidly changing
requirements in order to create products
that align with constantly evolving
business objectives the scrum alliance
offers a certified scrum master
certification if you want to get started
with scrum
the certification will assist you in
comprehending the scrum framework as
well as team roles events and other
assets
it will also allow you to teach scrum
ideas concepts and practices to your
organization
a certified scrum master can earn up to
a hundred thousand to 170 000 per annum
in the united states and up to 13 to 22
lakh rupees in india
now for number seven we have robotic
process automation rpa is a technique in
which businesses utilize ai and bots to
run their operations for instance if you
launch a web application to connect with
the support staff the first thing you'll
look into is the chat bot the chat bot
will present you with a variety of
questions and after you select one it
will offer you an immediate response to
your query
this is achieved using rpa to get into
this domain you will have to learn tools
such as blue prism uipath and automation
anywhere the uipath academy provides you
with free training depending on the
examination you opt for
also you can opt for automation testing
masters program by simplylearn
this course covers more than 15
automation testing tools and
technologies to make your profile stand
out as an automation test engineer
a certified rpa engineer can earn up to
eighty eight thousand to a hundred and
forty thousand per annum in the united
states and seven lakh to 20 lakh rupees
in india
now for number six pmp certification
project management entails managing a
team to achieve its objectives and be
successful within a given time frame
some of the best certifications you can
obtain for this domain are
first there is the project management
professional certification provided by
the project management professional
the certification addresses domain
concepts such as initiating planning
executing coordinating managing and
closing
you can also pick up simply learn's pmp
plus certification which covers the
concepts of project management scrum
master lean six sigma and much more
with the proper certification a project
manager can make seventy five thousand
to a hundred and forty four 000 per year
in the united states and up to 12 lakh
to 17 lakh rupees per year in india
next up we have number five big data
big data is a discipline that permits
the analysis extraction and management
of massive and complex data collections
the following are some common
certifications that you can pursue
the associate certified analytics
professional credential allows you to
begin the analytics process it focuses
on many analytics areas such as business
issue framing analytics problem framing
and many more
you could also pick up the ccp data
engineer certification
this certificate allows you to
demonstrate your knowledge of ingesting
transforming storing and analyzing data
in cloudera's cdh environment a big data
engineer can earn 121 000 to 250
000
per annum in the united states
in india he or she can earn close to
12.3 lakh to 33 lakh rupees per annum
with the right certification
at number four we have digital marketing
businesses can only succeed if their
targeted customers are aware of their
product or services
thus digital marketing is an essential
component of every company's operations
as the area of marketing has evolved in
the digital era the demand for experts
who have been trained in new abilities
has increased substantially
a digital marketing certification can
help you hone the skills such as seo ppc
web analytics content marketing and
social media
let's now have a look at some of the
best certifications you can pick up
first off you can take up simply learns
digital marketing specialist masters
certification
or you can take up certifications such
as google ads certification google
analytics certification and hubspot
content marketing certification
all of these certifications touch upon
concepts of digital marketing such as
seo content marketing ppc digital
analytics social media and so much more
a digital marketing manager could earn
sixty thousand to a hundred and sixty
000 in the united states and up to seven
lakh to 16 lakh rupees per annum in
india
next we have number three data science
it is a branch of computer science that
integrates scientific techniques
algorithms and systems to extract
information and insights from organized
and unstructured data
let's look at a few top certifications
that you can pick up for this domain
first and foremost there is ibm's data
science professional certification this
ibm backed certification may help you
get started with data science python sql
data analysis and visualization building
machine learning tools and much more
harvardx's data science professional
certificate is another option for
accreditation
it will cover our programming data
visualization essential data science
tools machine learning methods
probability inference and much more
by choosing the right certification a
data scientist can earn up to 115 000 to
246 000 in the united states and 8.2
lakh to 20 lakh in india
now for number two let's have a look at
cloud computing
no other area of it has produced as much
hype excitement and investment as cloud
computing during the last decade
according to idc by next year cloud will
attain a growth rate of 22
and a value of 277
billion dollars and because of this
there will undoubtedly be a high demand
for cloud experts
some of the popular cloud computing
certifications you can pick up are
the aws certified solutions architect
associate certification this
certification will enhance your ability
to architect deploy and secure
applications on aws
to use the appropriate architecture
designs and much more
you can also look into the microsoft
certified azure administration
certification which is ideal for people
who want to manage cloud services that
cover storage security networking and
cloud capabilities
a cloud computing engineer can earn up
to 145 000 to
227 000 in the united states and earn
close to 16 lakh to 24 lakh rupees in
india with the right certification
and finally we're at number one ai and
machine learning
what if machines can provide you with
optimal data-driven decisions by
perceiving patterns in previous data
sets how amazing will this be right
this astounding fact about ai and ml
domain has made it one of the most
popular career choices
in the previous year's trends ai has
shown a staggering 344 growth and the
right certification can help you do
wonders in this amazing domain a few of
them are simply learns postgraduate
program in ai and machine learning
created in partnership with purdue
university and in collaboration with ibm
covers a number of concepts like
statistics python machine learning deep
learning networks nlp
reinforcement learning and more
machine learning ai certification by
stanford available on coursera is also a
good resource this course includes an
introduction to machine learning data
mining statistical pattern recognition
the best practices in machine learning
and ai etc
an ai engineer can earn 140 000 to 386
000 in the united states and six to 20
lakh rupees in india
and there you go that's our top 10
certifications to take up in
2021 we are living in a time of flux
with jobs lost to automation while other
jobs require specific skills and
qualifications
and with 2022 rolling in if you are
giving your career some consideration to
make sure you are future proofing your
skill set or perhaps moving into a new
field altogether here's everything you
need to know about the top 10 highest
paid tech jobs in 2022
so let's look at them one by one at the
10th position we have systems analyst
in this role you will design techniques
to aid in problem solving by analyzing
it systems in the organization
they're responsible for fixing the
issues in a cost effective manner as an
analyst you will also test programs and
databases to make sure they're running
properly as well as run security audits
and documents on systems in the
organization some skills and
requirements for this job role are
analytical skills data analysis and
programming skills technical analysis
and project management the average
salary of systems analysts in the us is
about 145 000 usd per annum and in india
it's about 16 lakhs rupees per annum at
the ninth position we have blockchain
engineer a blockchain engineer
specializes in developing and
implementing architecture and solutions
using blockchain technology
the worldwide spending on blockchain
solutions is expected to reach 15.9
billion by 2023 meaning there will be
plenty of demand for blockchain experts
across industries and geographies
given the fact that cryptocurrencies are
surging blockchain technology has a long
way to go
from a bird's eye view a blockchain
engineer should have
solid programming skills and a thorough
understanding of the technologies behind
ripple r3 ethereum and bitcoin as well
as consensus methodologies and the
security protocol stacks crypto
libraries and functions the average
yearly salary of a blockchain engineer
in the us is about 150 000 usd and about
15 lakhs rupees per annum in india at
the eighth position we have product
manager a product manager helps
determine parameters around the product
while the engineering team leads the
development of that product from
conception to launch
some of the skills required for a
product manager are
a strong understanding of product life
cycle management plm
knowledge of product management tools
like pivotal tracker jira and asana
strong analytical and time management
skills
product managers are responsible for
delivering an operating plan that can
help achieve strategic and tactical
goals and objectives building a product
portfolio managing and implementing
marketing activities and contributing to
the product strategy and its vision
the average yearly salary of a product
manager is over 160 000 usd in the us
and about 25 lakhs rupees per annum in
india at number seven we have full stack
developer today there are over 23
million developers globally and by 2023
it could reach
27.7 million
definitely making it one of the highest
paid tech jobs in the industry a full
stack developer is someone who is well
versed in both front end and back end
development or someone with skills in
every stage of development from concept
to end product some of the knowledge and
skills required to become a pro full
stack developer is
technology such as mongodb
express.js angularjs and node.js how to
design and develop an api coding and
scripting the fundamentals of web
development basics of database
technologies
there is an ever-increasing demand for
full stack developers in the market
today
the average yearly salary of a full
stack developer in the us is about 164
000 usd and in india it's about 11 lakh
rupees per annum however with increasing
seniority comes increasing pay next in
the list of the highest paying jobs is a
devops engineer a devops engineer is
critical to the project's overall
success
right from planning to support to
customer satisfaction and productivity a
devops engineer has an essential role in
integrating the project functions and
resources across the product life cycle
right from planning building testing and
deployment to support
some of the skills required of a devops
engineer include coding and scripting
understanding deployment and network
operations familiarity with devops tools
like git and jenkins knowledge of linux
or unix system administration
devops engineers might be responsible
for designing and maintaining a
deployment infrastructure integrating
cloud services so that processes can be
automated or shell scripting in php
python and ruby the average yearly
salary of a devops engineer in the us is
about 176 000 usd and in india it's
about 11 lakh rupees per annum at the
fifth position we have data scientists
there has been a 29 increase in demand
for data scientists year over year and a
dramatic upswing of
344 increase since 2013. and for all the
right reasons
a data scientist analyzes and interprets
complex data to help organizations make
better and more timely decisions a data
scientist should be able to understand
machine learning algorithms create data
models code in language like python r
sas and other analytical tools identify
business issues and provide appropriate
solutions excellent communication the
yearly salary of a data scientist can be
as high as 184
500 usd in the u.s and about 15 lakhs
rupees in india
next in the list of highest paying jobs
is cloud architect
a cloud architect deploys and oversees
an organization's cloud computing
strategy
some of the skills and knowledge
required by cloud architects include a
thorough understanding of cloud
application architecture
knowledge of amazon web services azure
or google cloud platform
good knowledge of at least one operating
system computer programming languages
security and good communication skills
a cloud architect typically is
responsible for developing cloud
architecture developing a cloud strategy
and coordinating the implementation and
deployment of it and ensuring
application architecture and deployments
in the cloud environment are done
properly
the average yearly salary of a cloud
architect is 197 000 usd and 26 lakhs
rupees pa in india at number three we
have iot solutions architect one of the
most in demand and best paying jobs in
technology today is an iot solutions
architect the iot solutions architect is
a leadership role of overseeing the
strategy behind the development and
deployment of iot solutions in addition
to understanding iot solutions one
should also have strong programming
skills an understanding of machine
learning and knowledge of hardware
design and architecture
and in this highest paying tech job you
can earn an average of over 200 130 usd
and about 10 lakhs rupees annually at
the second position we have ai architect
an artificial intelligence ai architect
develops manages and oversees ai
initiatives within an organization
an ai architect should have deep
knowledge in mathematics and statistics
in addition an ai architect will have
solid programming skills and know python
r and torch
understand how tensorflow and other
similar technologies work have a clear
understanding about technologies related
to ai including machine learning neural
networks and deep learning
the average yearly salary of an ai
architect is about 230 000 usd and in
india the salary is about 63 lakhs
rupees per annum moving forward at the
first position we have software
architect
a software architect optimizes the
development process by making design
choices and dictating technical
standards such as coding tools and
platforms the candidate will be
responsible for designing developing and
implementing software solutions to
address complex business issues and
providing technical leadership within
the it department
some of the skills required of a
software architect include data modeling
an understanding of software
architecture good programming skills and
strong analytical skills the average
yearly salary of a software architect is
over 264
9447 usd and about 45 lakhs in india so
with that we come to the end of this
list although these are 10 of the best
paying jobs in technology plenty of
other fields like cyber security and
digital marketing are short on skilled
professionals so keep looking if none of
the careers described above appeal to
you
before i sign off make sure you
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update we'll
be back with more such interesting
videos until then keep learning and stay
tuned to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here